PEOPLE’S HOUSE VOTED TODAY TO
SPEND $2 TRILLION OF HOURS.
>> Shannon: ALL RIGHT, LELAND,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HOUSE LEADERSHIP WAS ABLE TO
BLOCK CONGRESSMAN MASSIE’S PLAN
TO FORCE A RECORDED VOTE, BUT
JUST THE FACT THAT HE FLOATED
THE PLAN THAT HUNDREDS OF HIS
COLLEAGUES WERE FORCED TO RETURN
TO WASHINGTON, AND MANY OF
THEM, FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE, LET HIM KNOW IN THE MIDST
OF THE COVID-19 SITUATION, THEY
WERE NOT HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
’S ARE TALKING EXCLUSIVELY TO
FOX NEWS AT NIGHT RIGHT NOW
ABOUT WHY HE DID WHAT HE DID,
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN FROM
KENTUCKY JOINS US LIVE.
CONGRESSMAN MASSIE, GOOD TO HAVE
YOU.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON,
SHANNON.
I GUESS I WAS ABLE TO FORCE THEM
TO COME TO WORK BUT I COULDN’T
FORCE THEM TO WORK.
ULTIMATELY, THEY CAME TO D.C.,
BUT THEY DECIDED NOT TO VOTE ON
IT AT ALL, AND THAT’S
UNFORTUNATE, BECAUSE I DIDN’T
DELAY THE VOTE AT ALL.
I THINK THAT IS WITH THE
PRESIDENT WAS UPSET WITH.
HE DIDN’T UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS
I WAS PROPOSING.
YOU KNOW, TUESDAY, THE SENATE
WAS HERE AND THEY WERE VOTING,
AND THE HOUSE -- THE HOUSE
LEADERSHIP, PELOSI AND
McCARTHY, SAID, YOU KNOW WHAT,
LET’S JUST PASS THIS ON
UNANIMOUS CONSENT AND TELL
EVERYBODY TO STAY HOME, DON’T
BOTHER COMING TO CONGRESS.
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT, SHANNON,
IS THIS IS THE THIRD CORONAVIRUS
BILL -- BY THE WAY, I VOTED FOR
THE FIRST ONE.
THIS IS THE THIRD ONE.
NANCY PELOSI ALREADY HAS A
FOURTH ONE PLAST KNOW MY
PLANNED.
IF YOU WATCH THE DEBATE,
DEMOCRATS ARE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
THEY’RE GOING TO PUT IN THE
FOURTH THE BILL, BUT YOU KNOW,
IF WE GET IN HIS HABIT OF JUST
PASSING BILLS AND NOBODY EVEN
COMES TO WORK WHEN THEY PASS,
THAT IS REALLY DANGEROUS.
THAT’S PAVING THE ROAD FOR
LOSI.
>> Shannon: OKAY, BUT YOU KNOW
THESE ARE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO
THOUGHT IT WAS DANGEROUS TO
BRING EVERYBODY BACK INCOME AT
ONE OF THEM WAS ONE OF YOUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUE, PETER
KING SAID THIS IN A TWEET:
"HOUSE PASSES PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY BILL, VICTORY FOR
AMERICA.
A LARGE NUMBER OF CONGRESS
MEMBERS HAD TO BE IN THE HOUSE
CHAMBER AND RISK INFECTION TO
THEMSELVES AND OTHERS BECAUSE OF
ONE ARROGANT MEMBER.
IF ANYBODY GETS INFECTED, BLOOD
IS ON REPRESENTATIVE
THOMAS MASSIE’S HANDS."
HOW DO YOU RESPOND?
>> THAT’S A PRETTY STRONG
STATEMENT.
THINK ABOUT THE ARROGANCE OF
THESE CONGRESSMEN.
THEY ARE TELLING THE TRUCKERS TO
KEEP DRIVING SO THEIR GROCERY
STORES WILL HAVE GROCERIES.
THEY ARE TELLING THE UPS DRIVERS
TO KEEP BRINGING THEIR AMAZON
PACKAGES.
THEY ARE TELLING THE BAGGER AT
THE GROCERY STORE TO KEEP
BAGGING GROCERIES.
BUT THESE CONGRESSMEN MAKE
$174,000 A YEAR.
THEY’VE GOT THE BEST HEALTH CARE
YOU CAN BUY THESE DAYS RIGHT
NOW.
AND THEY ARE TELLING PEOPLE THAT
THE CONGRESSMEN NEED TO STAY
HOME, BUT EVERYBODY ELSE NEEDS
TO WORK.
I THINK THAT IS THE WRONG
MESSAGE, BUT THAT REALLY GIVES
YOU A GLIMPSE INTO HOW SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., THINK.
>> Shannon: OKAY.
YOU SAID YOU WERE CONCERNED,
WHAT YOU WANTED WAS A RECORDED
VOTE WHERE EVERYBODY WOULD HAVE
TO SAY, YES OR NO.
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY SAID THERE WAS AN
APPROPRIATE VOTE.
HERE IS HIS TAKE ON THIS.
>> WE DO HAVE EVERYBODY ON THE
RECORD.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO
DO?
WE DIDN’T PASS WITH UNANIMOUS
CONSENT, I WOULD NEVER AGREE TO
THAT.
BUT WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE THREE
HOURS OF DEBATE.
WE HAD A VOICE VOTE FOR THOSE
WHO AREN’T ABLE TO MAKE IT, THEY
COULD ACTUALLY PUT ACROSS THE
DESK HOW THEY WOULD STAND ON THE
BILL.
>> Shannon: OKAY, SO THERE WAS
SOME DEBATE THERE.
HE SAYS HE WOULDN’T HAVE GONE
FOR A UNANIMOUS CONSENT BILL.
SO WHAT DIDN’T YOU GET THAT YOU
WANTED TODAY?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, THEY HAD
FOUR HOURS OF DEBATE AND
COULDN’T FIND ONE MINUTE TO
ALLOW ME TO DEBATE.
THAT’S BECAUSE THEY DON’T WANT
TO HEAR.
IF THE BILL IS SO GREAT, WHY
DIDN’T THEY WANT -- THE BOAT
HE’S TALKING ABOUT, WRITING HER
NAME ON A SLIP OF PAPER, THAT’S
NOT SHOWING UP IN CASTING A VOTE
THAT’S GOING TO BE RECORDED FOR
PROGRESSION RECORD.
IT IS NOT A REAL VOTE, HE WAS
TRYING TO HAVE A PRETEND TO VOTE
TO PLACATE EVERYBODY AND SAY YOU
COULD STAY HOME.
BY THE WAY, KEVIN McCARTHY
WANTS TO BE THE NEXT SPEAKER, SO
HE WANTED TO MAKE THIS AS EASY
AS HE COULD ON EVERYBODY.
HE WAS TRYING TO BE SANTA CLAUS
AND SAY, YOU CAN STAY HOME, AND
YOU DON’T REALLY HAVE TO VOTE.
WE WILL PRETEND LIKE WE ARE
BUILDING HERE, AND THEN WE WILL
TELL EVERYBODY THAT’S WHAT IT
IS.
THE PROBLEM WITH KEVIN’S PLAN AS
IT DIDN’T SATISFY THE
CONSTITUTION.
I LITERALLY HAD TO TWEET THE
CONSTITUTION, AND SHAME
EVERYBODY, BASICALLY, INTO
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT IF YOU DON’T
HAVE A QUORUM, YOU CAN’T PASS A
BILL IN CONGRESS.
TO MR. KING’S POINT, ONLY HALF
OF CONGRESS HAD TO SHOW UP TODAY
TO PASS THIS BILL.
AND IT DIDN’T DELAY THE BILL I
EVEN AN HOUR, BECAUSE I TOLD
EVERYBODY WHAT MY PLAN WAS A
DAY AGO.
SO THAT THEY HAD TIME TO GET
HERE.
>> Shannon: YEAH, AND MANY OF
THEM WERE NOT HAPPY ABOUT THAT,
BECAUSE OF THE, YOU KNOW,
WARNINGS AGAINST TRAVEL.
TWO MORE MEMBERS OF EUROS TO
DATE ANNOUNCED THEY TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID-19, AS WELL.
YOU EARNED YOURSELF A NAME
MR. NOEL FROM "POLITICO,"
BECAUSE YOU DO WILL VOTE NO ON
SO MANY THINGS.
I KNOW YOU HAVE YOUR REASONS,
AND WE THANK YOU FOR COMING